on vit une situation très compliquée
malheureusement très difficile qu'il ya
certainement beaucoup d'entre vous qui
se trouve cette période longue et
difficile
l'organisation mondiale de la santé est
particulièrement préoccupée par les
problèmes de santé mentale en
particulier c'est facile de se sentir
impuissant anxieux
juste mal par rapport à la situation
actuelle
psychologiquement c'est c'est forcément
très difficile pour chacun d'entre nous
en tout cas moi je le ressens à titre
individuel c'est difficile de comprendre
et parfois c'est difficile de garder le
moral c'est difficile de vouloir parler
interagir via internet
il ya des vies des messages privés à des
appels téléphoniques et je ressens aussi
avec les personnalités j'interagis c'est
une période difficile pour tout le monde
et du coup je pense que c'est très
important de chaque jeu pour qu'on
prenne soin de chacun d'entre nous quoi
et qu'on pense à nous mêmes et à nos
proches dans cette période difficile
essayer d'améliorer notre état mental et
à ce sujet il ya quelques références que
que que je me permets de lui recommander
je suis pas absolument pas de ce qui la
tue pas du tout les experts du domaine
mais ces sont des lectures qui est des
vidéos qui m'ont beaucoup aidé à titre
personnel donc particulier le livre
feeling good de ta vie de burns qui a
aussi un peu de caste du même nom je
pense que c'est beaucoup d'habitudes du
quotidien de réflexe émotionnel qui sont
en fait très utile pour se sentir mieux
commander aussi pas mal de choses qui
parlent de cette branche qui s'appelle
les thérapies cognitives
comportementales notamment les vidéos de
blanche qui parle très bien de cela il
ya aussi des vidéos d'eux
de cyrus noir qui sont très chouette
récemment sur tout tout tout ces sujets
difficiles et puis à la vidéo de les
vidéos de courses au japon particules à
vidéo de course correcte sur l'a10
satisfaction l'insatisfaction d'une
vidéo qui voit là notamment les des
publications scientifiques qui montrent
que le fait d'exprimer régulièrement sa
gratitude être beaucoup à se sentir
mieux
d'un point de vue mental notamment il ya
pas mal d'exercice qui sont recommandées
par exemple chaque soir écrire sur un
carnet où un bout de papier des raisons
pour avoir ce sentiment de gratitude
envers la situation présente qui
forcément est difficile comparé à
période d'avant par exemple mais il ya
quand même je pense pas mal de choses
tout on peut néanmoins exprimé pas mal
de reconnaissance moi à titre personnel
je suis extrêmement confiante par
exemple déjà d'avoir un logement c'est
vraiment une chance inouïe et le fait de
me le répéter au quotidien de répéter
tout ce qui va bien d'avoir des amis
la famille des gens qui me supportent ça
me permet de bien mieux vivre cette
situation pour agir est aussi à
réfléchir à toutes les raisons d'être
reconnaissant tout en acceptant qu'il y
avait également beaucoup des difficultés
de plus plus généralement
l'insatisfaction c est une tension entre
le monde tel qu'on pense qu'il devrait
être et non de tel qu'il est vraiment et
tant qu'on n'a cette divergence est
importante on pense que le montat qui
leur est et devrait être largement mieux
que le monde tel qu'il est bah c'est
très naturel de nourrir un sentiment de
frustration ou de gloire de ressentiment
donc une solution qui est pas mal
évoqués dans le livre feelgood pour
éviter cette frustration qui peut
ensuite posé des problèmes de santé
mentale avancer c'est de reconnaître le
fait que le monde
il est tel qu'il est et de l'accepter
tel qu'il est et peut-être aussi de
revoir de façon plus
plus réaliste plus pragmatique notre
vision du monde de tel qui devrait être
surtout en situation de pandémie
comme l'expliquent cyrus dans cette
vidéo en fait la situation est plus
compliquée pour tout le monde y compris
si on avait été à la place de l'exécutif
il ya d'édition qui sont juste difficile
à prendre et c'est pas clair et
l'horizon est très très flou la
situation du coc u19 est juste une
situation très très compliqué pour tout
le monde
je vais aussi partager aussi mon
expérience personnelle d activité
physique qui joue un rôle très important
dans mon bien-être mental ou ludiques
sont général donc par exemple
comme vous avez peut-être pu le suivre
sur les réseaux sociaux
j'ai commencé à apprendre à jongler
cours depuis depuis novembre et c'est
une expérience qui et qui fait beaucoup
beaucoup donné au ca me permettant de me
détacher de toutes les préoccupations et
il ya et l'activité physique à être
beaucoup au bien-être tout cas ça semble
être le cas pour la plupart des gens
donc je vous encouragera assez
entreprendre quelques activités
physiques langage est particulièrement
adaptée mais réfléchir à d'autres
activités que vous pourriez faire c'est
possible en restant chez vous sinon on
va prendre l'air se balader faire du
footing
c'est vraiment important pour le bien
être mental tout cas ça a l'air d'être
vraiment utile poids pour la plupart des
gens que si ce n'est pas une habitude
que vous avez si vous vous sentez mal
peut-être essayer de vous forcer un peu
a essayé de faire ce genre d'activité
est ensuite analysé quel est l'impact de
ses activités sur votre bien-être s'il
est positif c'est de continuer et enfin
la dernière chose c'est prenez soin de
vous mais également
de vos proches la situation risque de
durer après l'avoir de voir le bout du
tunnel
en tout cas dans les mois à venir ça
risque d'être encore très compliqué et
c'est là que la solidarité
l'empathie à la compassion vont jouer un
rôle très important pour surmonter les
difficultés psychologiques
de nous mêmes mais aussi de nos proches
c'est vrai j'aimerais encourager à
prendre soin de vous et à prendre soin
de vos proches